hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freundinnen lang lang ist's her dass ich
das letzte mal brenner und gespielt habe
von daher herzlich willkommen hier heute
zu einem neuen video in dem ich spiele
wir fangen direkt an beim rätseln nummer
104 war mir im letzten video stehen
geblieben würde das fragezeichen aus wir
haben eine 23 450 hasse so was ich
konnte noch nie ich habe keinen plan
mehrmals soll jetzt schon keinen spaß
mehr im tipps steht dass das
fragezeichen 1 90 ist es ist halt super
tipp wenn es einfach die lösung ist also
geben wir mal ein 90 1 wahnsinn ohne
tempolimit flüge eine linie hinzu um
diese gleichung fahrt so es ist wieder
mathe mann
[Musik]
sie gab so habe ich auch mein abi dann
geschafft jag vill saft trinken dann
trinkt auch saft ist natürlich falsch
cola ist wahrscheinlich noch keinen saft
müssen wir das irgendwie übereinander
packen es gibt auch nicht cola um den
saft ziehen geht auch nicht abschütteln
manchmal ist es ja so dass ja ich hasse
dieses spiel umdrehen denn auch nicht
kulawik bruder trinkt als saft schüttle
ihn bevor du ihn ihm
es ist euer ernst ich habe es gerade
geschüttelt
es ist falsch ich schüttele es und gibt
ihm
es ist falsch was sagt dann schüttelt
war das sieht ja auch nicht geschüttelt
jetzt eben dieses spiel
hat nichts mit intelligenz zu tun der
ich hin traum möchtest du verwirklichen
reise um die welt schlank und wohlhabend
oder werde hübscher also ich glaube mal
reise um die welt nie lang und
wohlhabend nicht auf falsche hübscher
auch falsch ich irgendwas acts ihn nie
welchen traum möchte ich kann ja nichts
machen das schütteln wieder fällt ein
neuer ist raum umdrehen nee ich krieg
wieder auf dem tisch drauf clique gleich
zu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich kriege ich die krise
nächstes rätsel und zwar mittlerweile
schon nummer 108 wir sollten einfach die
schachtel öffnen jetzt nicht und nicht
an summen geht auch nicht so umdrehen
ihn nicht zoomen auch nicht schütteln
geht auch nicht an seinen reaktionen
gedrückthalten auseinander ziehen
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich drin hat ein bisschen
gedauert aber jetzt bin ich drin
ich hatte was ist die antwort eins ist
gleich 52 ist gleich 15 3 215 4 3215 und
5 ist eine 5 am ende hier 32 15 ich war
schon immer gut in mathe wie viele
unterschiede kannst du zwischen den
beiden bildern erkennen also wie das
sind extrem wieder
ja wir fangen mal gesondert an
wir haben die gabel die schoko teile die
falsch angeordnet sind das ist der
zweite wir haben eine farbveränderung
bei der muffin verpackung und rot zu
blau dass der dritte genau wird aber
dass auch ohne raten hingekriegt tippe
zehnmal auf die blaue schaltfläche und
dann einmal auf die roten 123456 im 89
der wort mit falschen herbst mit den
verschiedenen zahlen nicht mit lot war
schon immer gut aber man halte die waage
im gleichgewicht irgendwie hier
irgendwie nicht kartoffeln erwarte ich
mir einfach alles unter ach ja immer den
luca toni jubelt guck mal hier meinen
gehen radschrauben eufinger fälle erneut
die anzahl der haare das hat mir in
einem der letzten videos und zwar hab
jetzt mal mir nämlich wollten die
kommentare geschrieben ich konnte
einfach die zwei steinen hier 24
1729 +9 sind 38 m matte mein ding schon
immer gewesen wird immer sein was ist
die antwort es ist wieder irgendwas mit
zahlen
die drei kätzchen zusammen sind 30 dass
es eine katze ist 20 richte ich halte
aber eine katze ist sehen hier haben wir
dann 10 + 5 + 5 + 22 also eine fotos
jeweils 1 und dann haben wir hier unten
fünf plus eins mal diese katze die aber
lernen arm fehlt so die katze unten
rechts
die hieß jahrzehnten ohne einen arm der
1 bedeutet also 99 x 1 sind neun dh es
sind 14
[Musik]
ich musste der uni heute unterrichtet
und fasst man könnte meinen ich habe
studiert heute ist deix zweiter
geburtstag lieber teig alles alles gute
zum geburtstag
wir zünden jetzt einfach mal die kerzen
an sondern einfach
herzen anja
ist das falsch sind alle an
denn ernst also ich habe es geschafft
meinen die partei alles wie heißt
überhaupt teig bruder was bist du
nebenberuflich pizza boden das tut
einfach für rätsel nummer 116 winde die
mutter erneut also wir können hier
wieder so ein bisschen rum scrollen kann
mir gar nicht ich nehm ich jetzt mal
ganz weit aus dem fenster
mach ich doch nicht weil es regnet aber
dieser job schon wieder was ist wenn
mein gehirn los aber ich glaube und das
wollte ich gerade sagen es gab noch nie
so eine lange strecke von luca schafft
brain autorin ohne sich den tipp zu
kaufen
hilft der ente wasser zu trinken trinken
einfach wasser natürlich geht das nicht
wir können steine in den himmel schweiz
in der land- regnet
wo sollte ich jetzt nicht irgendwie
dienten
es muss ja irgendwas bedeuten hier
steine haben hier die wolken über die
wolken hier eintauchen in den stein
wolken von roddick
[Musik]
warum auch youtube videos
christian drosten ich bin noch etwas ist
jetzt eine körpertemperatur
[Musik]
hey stofffetzen tipp legen den finger
auf das thermometer messen
[Musik]
wow wirklich also dann bei sowas reist
an meine serie oder hat egal machen wir
weiter mit diesem rätsel hier mische rot
und blau zusammen kann ich irgendwie
muss ich schütteln
[Musik]
er hat gar nicht aber wie wird man denn
man macht doch so oder nicht sagt kommen
können wir uns einen tipp freude
verwendet einen finger um die öffnung zu
bleiben
[Musik]
macht euren scheiß allein hilfe wo ist
mein ring fragt sich die stadtteile hier
ist sie zusätzlich zwei airports als
hände
hier ist mal eine dose hundefutter
hundefutter gehen wir dem hund oder wenn
wir das nicht erst mal aufmachen das
hundefutter nehme ich weiß nicht wie
geht das okay das hundefutter hass auf
du ist das bitte perfekt den räten
natürlich der hund hat den ring
gefressen und uns jetzt ausgepackt man
kennt man kennt
wir haben wir sind jetzt meist nicht
kommen freunde machen wir noch ein
allerletztes rätsel hier als neuer
meister of brain out macht das licht
wieder aus mitteln schlagen kaputt
machen auch nicht zoomen
[Musik]
ich habe keine ahnung wie ich das
hingekriegt habe aber genau das dachte
ich mir auch bei meinem studium an der
stelle wird das sollte ich wieder jetzt
allerdings auch beende meine lieben
freunde ich habe euch ja auf instagram
gefragt ob ich heute mal wieder brett
oder fordert hochladen soll und ihr habt
entschieden
reynaud sollte es werden deswegen ist es
das ganze jetzt auch geworden wenn es
euch gefallen hat das kind einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da erfolgt wir
gerne auf instagram benny demnächst auch
entscheiden wird was sich hochladen und
jetzt befinden wir uns auch im auto wenn
ihr hier oben auf den 2 darauf könnt ihr
kostenlos meinen kanal abonnieren
verpasst dadurch keine videos mehr uns
hier unten ist der letzte teil brainard
verlinkt ist es schon mehrere wochen
herd allerdings ihr habt entschieden es
ist mal wieder online gegangen hier
bringt mit mir eurem genie schlechthin
das anklickt da drauf ich bin raus